[Music]
twitch chat is juxtaposed overtop of
pokey mains webcam feed Pepe the Frog
emotes run northbound on the right side
of the screen frantically they're
looking for that big-money Max's twitch
rival champions she just won the twitch
rivals League of Legends finals she's
smiling ear-to-ear just chatting with
her subscribers sorry I'm talking so
much I love you guys this like the best
date browsing the web checking her
Twitter feed and catching up on the
goings-on of the gaming and content
creation world pokey roasted focuses
another day another pokey stream with
tens of thousands of people watching but
the channel couldn't be more relaxed
that's the kind of energy pokey brings
tomorrow she's flying to the NFL Pro
Bowl where she'll be a special guest at
the events fortnight celebration to her
right is where Mimi hangs out her
beloved cat she periodically explodes
with love for
[Music]
she's in the master bedroom with the
offline TV house in Los Angeles this is
pokey main a passionate streamer that
will dominate any sphere of content put
in her path all while maintaining the
nonchalant attitude she is universally
loved for Kumar can you do this
back off ma'am guests ladies all right
with this sword
I found a protect all changes oh yes yes
I'm sorry I've never seen any of the Toy
Story movies
[Music]
this is her story
[Music]
Iman pokey main anis lives and breathes
content whether you're watching
fortnight on Twitch browsing YouTube or
scrolling through Instagram chances are
you've heard her name pokey was born in
Morocco but grew up in Quebec City
Canada where she grew up speaking French
as her first language as a little like
five year old my brain couldn't
comprehend how I lived in a city named
Quebec in a province named Quebec that
was the first place that I moved to and
we lived from Morocco to Canada
she started her trek up the content
creation ladder in June 2013 when she
first activated her twitch channel this
was an era in gaming when eSports was
really starting to thrust itself into
the heart of the online zeitgeist and
league of legends in particular was
surging in popularity back then
streaming a game like League on twitch
was about showing off just how good you
were
[Applause]
we were light years away from the just
chatting section and the
personality-driven broadcasters we know
now but pokey main shattered that mold
not only did she offer a gameplay she
brought you right into her world like
really really really minty gum the minty
gum that isn't sweet not really a bubbly
University student who loved anime
makeup cats and hip-hop
she allowed her viewers to get to know
her as a person in an era where that
kind of content wasn't the norm and she
flourished in addition to streaming on
Twitch she started a YouTube channel and
filled it with highlights vlogs and
lifestyle content hi everyone today I am
cosplaying
of course back then a poky mainstream
wasn't the same polished product it is
today she like many other content
creators was trying to balance her
channel with her everyday life I
she was studying chemical engineering at
McMaster University in Hamilton Ontario
and in true poki style was seamlessly
blending her identity as a student with
her content in many ways this was the
genesis of what maybe poki means
greatest asset her uncanny ability to
turn each part of her lifestyle into
independent uniquely provocative content
streams even early on she didn't just
play League or stream or unbox or vlog
she also published streaming tips and
cosplay videos once people really enjoy
who you are and I like feel some type of
a connection with that they're happy to
watch you play or do just about anything
there's a lot made of putting your
entire self on display in your content
and for poky mean that felt authentic
from the beginning everything that
people say or do or think about you can
be a bit more on a personal level I try
to just let the fact that I am the
product in the sense motivate me to
become a better person in all aspects of
life from 2015 to 2016 pokeyman began to
grow exponentially on YouTube and twitch
at times she was streaming to more than
2,000 viewers and was attracting
non-endemic sponsors to
channel the point at which I really saw
myself taking more of a career path with
streaming was when I saw sponsorships
and sponsors and brands in general
coming into the space I felt like that
really not only legitimized the space
but also showed me a way to get actual
stable income with the growth she was
enjoying she decided to drop out of
school and take a big risk she put her
life on hold left her degree and the
country she grew up in and moved to Los
Angeles the mecca of eSports to give
streaming full-time a shot this decision
turned out to be a massive success after
a failed first living arrangement led to
the origins of offline TV offline TV
came about basically I decided to take a
year off of school when I wanted to test
out streaming full-time and during that
time I was like I should move down to LA
because that's like the hub of eSports
basically so I came down here my living
situation kind of didn't work out so I
was looking for a place and I was under
the same agency that scarra was under
and also our manager at the time was
living with him and he was living with
another league player named you know
they had an extra room like can I live
with you guys please just for a little
bit please up homeless in the span of a
few short months pokey main went from
being an up-and-coming streamer who was
learning to balance her university
workload with her content creation to
living in LA with a dedicated group of
like-minded content creators I was like
you know what I'll double the investment
get a bigger house and grab some people
I wasn't make like an actual content
house I wasn't try for it again because
especially with pokey coming in I was
like I really like pokey I think the
dynamic I like me you know pokey could
be is really good and then like plus a
couple people who knows I think we can
kill it
and pokey main exploded by the end of
2017
she was streaming to more than 5,000
viewers concurrently and gained more
than 450,000 twitch followers making her
one of the top 100 broadcasters on the
platform but most importantly she
continued to be the multi-purpose
entertainer she had become known for at
the request of her followers she created
an ASMR focused youtube channel which be
came an instant success that same year
she ramped up the content on her main
YouTube channel and generated more than
500,000 subscribers in 2017 alone on
YouTube she gave her subscribers a
little bit of everything you could tune
in for stream highlights and more gaming
and Jason content if that's what you
wanted but she also went outside of the
box
creating monthly vlogs of events she
attended and gave viewers a glimpse into
her day-to-day life and in that same
year she took to Instagram as well where
she generated more than 300,000
followers on a platform that was still
mostly untapped by the gaming industry
poki used Instagram to capitalize on
something that has been a fixture of her
content since the beginning her interest
in fashion and beauty on stream there's
a constant back and forth between her
and her community on these subjects it's
like four words something stars I order
it it comes in I open it and you know
what I get this these bottles are two
different colors entirely she'll teach
you how she does her hair what makeup
she uses new techniques and new outfits
her Instagram is an extension of all
that and has become massively popular as
a result but there was still upward
progress waiting for poki into
when the gaming world as we knew it
would be flipped on its head while pokey
was getting bigger she never stayed
static in her approach to her content
she stayed willing to adapt and was
always looking for the next big thing to
move the needle and she found it in 2018
pokey main left headfirst into one of
the biggest gaming phenomena in history
fortnight Battle Royale it's been
discussed ad nauseam but it's hard to
understate the positive relationship
between the battle royale genre and
twitch streamers the games provide a
cadence that allows for ample
back-and-forth with the living organism
that is twitch chat in addition to
seemingly constant gameplay for pokey
main fortnight was the perfect fit after
all so much of her identity on twitch
was tied to her personality sure League
fans loved her commitment to the game
and memeing on the rift but she wasn't
just a league of Legends streamer she
was a five-tool entertainer and
fortnight was the perfect canvas for her
to paint on
oh my god that's so close and I started
reloading I was like I knocked one
beside you and as fortnight grew so did
pokey main with the addition of
fortnight to her repertoire there was
simply nothing stopping pokey main
offline TV was growing rapidly her
YouTube and twitch were both exploding
and she had perched herself high atop
the rankings as one of the most popular
personalities in the gaming world pokey
capped off 2018 by being recognized for
her massive growth over the course of
the year by winning streamer of the Year
at the Shorty Awards anyone out there if
you have a passion follow it it'll be
worth it it's also important to note
that many of these worlds in which she's
become a trailblazing force are
particularly difficult to navigate for
women I do think that being a woman in
gaming definitely comes with its
difficulties as well as its pros and
also I feel like it's luckily gotten
better and better every year but with
the tenacity and professionalism that
poky brings to her work she's become a
juggernaut in the world of content
creation but as is always the case with
pokey while everything else was razor
focused on fortnight she was conquering
another platform in her spare time
despite her overwhelming fame and gaming
pokey was also developing another kind
of following on Instagram her makeup and
beauty content has attracted a massive
non-endemic audience on Instagram that
has landed her with more than 3.5
million followers
in fact she's such a force on the
platform that sponsors started to take
notice I'm a creator not all
in the online sense but just in the like
up here so it was like I'm always
thinking of new ideas making new things
I want to do and I've always found not
necessarily the act of putting something
online having people enjoy that to be
satisfying but the act of like creating
something in your mind envisioning it
and then producing it and having that
become reality that's what's really
satisfying it's here that as we
mentioned earlier pokey main sets
herself apart the thing that I love the
most about doing this collaboration is
that it's something that's never really
been done in the twitch space it's as if
she has her own gravitational pull of
influence it really really warms my
heart when other female streamers say
that I inspire them I want to continue
making it like a very comfortable space
for a wide variety of people and
showcasing that I feel like gaming is a
lot more diverse than people might
realize she layers an infectious
personality on top of extremely popular
and relatable content
she doesn't limit herself to any one
form of creating she sees a new avenue
to grow and attacks it every time I
gotta say I think every year gaming
becomes a more and more mainstream so I
try to never be afraid to kind of step
out of my comfort zone and definitely
the key for me is to only tackle content
that I'm genuinely passionate about and
she does it like no other content
creator on the planet it's typically for
me just when I see something that I like
and I enjoy the platform that it's on I
try to figure out you know how I can
replicate the things that I like about
it I like you maybe innovate in that
community or in the areas of if you
lacking in that community and see how
well I can get it to perform
she's your afternoon companion someone
to catch up on the Internet news of the
day with to listen to the latest Drake
track or explore the latest fortnight
patch but I saw really good clip with it
earlier today oh my god they vaulted my
honey rifle that was my favorite gun
she'll help you do your makeup better
she'll laugh with you and she'll just
kick back and do what feels like nothing
at all for eight hours nearly every day
with you guys please don't shoot on me
for saying this but like I've never seen
any of the Toy Story movies it's an
absolute master class in making things
look easy honestly just like Google mean
I think I might make a tick-tock isn't
that wild
let's go a mile I just love that
honestly just go goofy Google me thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages